but make no mistake
if any object presents a threat to the
safety security of the American people I
will take it down
tough talking President Biden finally
addressing the American public on what
the hell is going on in our skies he
tried to clear things up but in true
Biden fashion only made them worse the
White House started the week floating
the idea the Pentagon may have shot down
UFOs or aliens but now it could just be
junk from private companies
we don't yet know exactly what these
three objects were but nothing nothing
right now suggests they were related to
China's spy balloon program or that
there were surveillance vehicles from
other any other country
the intelligence community's current
assessment is that these three objects
were most likely balloons tied to
private companies I want to be clear
we don't have any evidence that there
has been a sudden increase in the number
of objects in the sky we're now just
seeing more of them
but it could be more ridiculous than
that a hobby Club in Illinois thinks
that one of its small balloons is quote
missing in action and they're worried
Biden shot it down if true that means we
just wasted four hundred thousand
dollars to take out a 12 balloon and
earlier this week the Geniuses at the
White House suggested they were used to
Car Lot balloons
and after reacting incredibly slowly the
president pretended that he's been on
top of the situation since the beginning
when I came into office I instructed our
intelligence Community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial objects
okay
um the president made it clear today in
his presser three weeks after they say
they knew that that spycraft flew over
the illusions that their three balloons
are innocuous they're either
recreational or they may be testing the
uh the weather uh and they shoot them
down to the tune of 1.2 million dollars
the one that they knew was a Chinese
spycraft they allowed it to kind of
hover over our sensitive middle size of
missile sites and they they didn't shoot
it down until after it did its Mission
so what is our policy if we don't know
what it is we shoot it down and if we
know it's China we let it do its work
and then shoot it down right so if
you're a hobbyist you better watch out
but if you're China spying on us you
know you can go all the way to South
Carolina this is the bottleneck balloon
Brigade Janine out of Northern Illinois
a few Fathers and Sons get together on
the weekends and this is what they do
they buy a 12 balloon and when you go to
a birthday party you know those
canisters of helium they get a canister
and they inflate the balloon the size of
maybe two Greg gutfelds and then they
put a little device for tracking on it
twist it and then they let it fly and
then they go on their phones and then
they see a little red dot and then they
follow the Red Dot around and see where
it goes they're literally seeing where
the wind blows Janine
but to Biden these people are kamikazes
and he will not rest until every
father-son hobby balloon outfit
paranoid Jesse he will not rest until
they're all shot out of the sky so he
spent four hundred thousand dollars on a
missile to kill a 12 balloon
but if you're China fly all you want but
he claims judge that they didn't get
anything now how long have we been
claiming the Chinese didn't see anything
every time the Chinese do anything we
claim whether it's Hunter small well
whether it's Diane in California that
they didn't get anything yet China
continues to grow from all of our
technology it's just a coincidence that
everything they steal winds up back in
Beijing at half price and do you believe
also that Joe Biden his first act as
commander-in-chief gathered the generals
around the situation report gentlemen I
want our first mission to be not a
single balloon will enter American
airspace until we know exactly what it
is
he didn't know I did Joe Biden he's not
even known as a UFO guy he's not even
known as an Air Force guy that never
happens so you were suggesting that he
was not telling the truth I'm suggesting
whoever wrote that for him it would have
been prescient he could have known that
this it would be the first time okay so
why is no one taking credit for these
three balloons other than the hobby
company uh or the club and uh how is it
that Joe Biden is so sure uh Jessica
that it's that that quote it's it's he
says that nothing suggests that it those
balloons are from China when we haven't
even retrieved those three balloons yet
why is he so sure
I assume someone told him he wasn't on
the ground
no I don't think Xi Jinping called him
up and said you've been shooting down
toy balloons and don't worry they're not
ours uh I assume someone who wears a
uniform has told him that that's the
case and it is
we're leaving on one hand to know that
we're sure and we are tracking these spy
balloons that are coming from China it
feels less relieving to say to look at
it as that we're essentially taking them
at their word that they didn't pick up
anything again that this was inadvertent
and John tester who's one of President
Biden's biggest allies in the Senate
came out and just said that there's
nothing inadvertent about anything that
China does so we really have to lose
that talking point
um I'm disappointed because I love the
UFO alien talk and the fact that he's
ruling that out at least seemingly is
disappointing but I guess there are just
hundreds of these floating around all
the time and we got nervous because of
the Chinese Bible and just started
shooting them all down and yeah that's
what we're going to be doing from now on
yes that's pretty much it so they know
it's not from China but did Biden Dana
miss an opportunity to Define China to
the American people and what a
relationship is he does all the time
like what he said today he could have
said on Monday
what's the difference they knew they I
think they knew pretty quickly oh boy
that was that one is by that wasn't a
spycraft
um I can't wait to see the New York Post
cover tomorrow it's going to be
delicious I have no idea what it's going
to say but I know it's going to be very
good I can't believe that Biden didn't
come out and say I was right initially
they should have listened to me because
he's according to him he said to the
generals immediately when he heard about
when he first heard about the balloon
over Alaska I guess shoot it down
and the generals were the ones who said
actually no way that might be too
dangerous even though it was over vast
Wilderness expanses so he usually would
probably maybe on background in the
morning we'll see somebody from the
White House saying Joe Biden was right
and too bad they didn't listen to him
the other thing is it wasn't just uh
four hundred thousand dollars it was
eight hundred thousand dollars for this
one hobby balloon yeah
balloons that we don't know
it's the evasive capabilities it's 1.6
million so all of that could have been
said on Monday now we have a whole new
task force right so now all these guys
are gonna have to get together and talk
about balloons all the time and but we
mentioned the cost what about the cost
of losing face around the world this is
pretty embarrassing on Sunday when that
first was reported a friend sent me a
note saying oh wow some kids Christmas
drone just got blown out of the sky I
laughed about it it turns out that it's
true but the last thing I want to say is
uh so the president is late to give
comments he gets pushed into giving
comments it gives comments and then he
looks like he's going to take questions
and then he doesn't like it that one
that one it was chaotic they were
yelling that's because they never get to
ask him a question
one of the guys was asking about the
Chinese relationship and he was they
looked like he wanted to answer that
question but there was another person
over here according to Peter Ducey
yelling more loudly about the Biden
family relationship with China and
that's when the president said
oh come on man and they'll come back
when people can be more polite I I've
read the Constitution the First
Amendment there's nothing that says that
the reporters have to be polite it's
nice when they can be polite but when
there's never an opportunity to ask the
president questions that's the kind of
thing that you're going to get yeah he
got heated you know Greg Kamala Harris I
mean our vice president she says that
China's spy balloon situation doesn't
damage our relations with China I think
that because their balloon wasn't blown
up until after it did its work that
China is a protected class and I think
Kamala thinks the same I don't know you
know I think this might be the most
exciting thing to ever happen to a hobby
Club
maybe it was when Billy found a Playboy
in an abandoned tree house but then all
of a sudden you were a national story
because of your homemade weather balloon
which it probably is and which was all
over Twitter there were pictures of it a
cartoonist of all people was showing the
showing what what it was but then you
have the president and it was such a
small oppressor like him waddling away
grinning like a confused patient who
wandered you know out the rest home
property and then shaking his fist at
the clouds I'll get you balloons he's
like a a bully who got his butt kicked
so he decides to take it out on three
smaller people on the way home it's like
to try to get the China balloon made him
look like a fool so I'm gonna shoot down
three weathered balloons just to show
you they're just innocent weather
balloons minding their own business what
kind of monster are you I think the
Hobby Lobby is behind this by the way
you know what the thing is though uh
this might be the most expensive
carnival game in history yeah I mean
think about it if the pilots land
whoever hits a balloon they should get a
big giant stuffed animal or a or a like
a a a glad bag filled with one goldfish
one goldfish yes you get two tries you
get two tries that's what that's right
but the Sidewinder that's pretty special
that's a great story I mean it turned
out to be it's hilarious I mean we're in
an era where there's war and we're
talking about balloons not to tell Joy
about it and I know that I do this all
the time but you'll like my point I
think this time so it ended up being
funny but you don't want to forget the
really serious part that a couple weeks
ago there was a Chinese spy below
what he can't explain the glamoring
contradiction as it just was different
she can't say oh why didn't I do that
that's why I'm surprised he didn't say
they should have listened to me yeah
yeah
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now